could you incorporate an emoji like into
the language into the main language
do you have a favorite one well I really
like uh in terms of humor like uh Raw
full whatever rolling on the floor
laughing
so that could be like a
what would that be the use case for that
like an except throw an exception of
some sort I don't know you should
totally file a feature request
uh or maybe a hard one it has to be a
hard one uh people have told me that I'm
insane so this is this is this is I'm
liking this
I'm gonna I'm gonna use the viral nature
of the internet to to actually get this
to get this past uh I mean it's funny
you come back to the flame Emoji file
extension right the uh um you know we
have the option to use the flame Emoji
which just even that concept cause for
example the people at GitHub say now
I've seen everything
yeah there's something uh it kind of
it's reinvigorating it's like uh
it's like oh that's possible that's
really cool that for some reason that
makes everything else I'm really excited
the world is ready for this stuff right
and so you know when we have a package
manager we'll clearly have to innovate
by having the compiled package thing be
the little box with the bow on it right
I mean
it has to be done it has to be done